des policiers à chaque coin de rue selon
les autorités policières londonienne
jamais la ville n'avait connu pareille
opération de protection dignitaires qui
sont arrivés des quatre coins de la
planète que c'était une personne très
respecté à travers le monde depuis très
longtemps et mon expérience je vais
rencontrer au canada mais beaucoup à
l'étranger comme un voile il demain
elles étaient toujours hors jeu d'être
quand elle arrivait quelques 2000
personnes devraient assister aux
funérailles à l'abbaye de westminster
parmi elles cinq cents dignitaires
étrangers l'occasion de rencontres
informelles
est formel comme ces réunions
bilatérales avec les premiers ministres
australien matthew goss
et ukrainienne puis loin des caméras par
égard au deuil national
justin trudeau s'est rendu au 10 downing
street pour s'entretenir avec la
nouvelle première ministre li strass
elle représente la droite du parti
conservateur britannique leurs
politiques ne sont pas toutes alignées
mais le canada et le royaume-uni
partagent un intérêt marqué pour le sort
de l'ukraine nous avions été une
continuons d'être parmi les pays n'est
plus fermement en appui à l'ukraine est
opposé évidemment à aux actions
illégales et immorales de la russie
justin trudeau ainsi que d'autres
dignitaires étrangers ont été conviés à
une réception offerte par charles iii ou
palais de buckingham bien que le nouveau
monarque était préparé toute sa vie à ce
rôle la côte d'amour n'a pas suivi
cela pourrait-il fragiliser les liens
avec la monarchie au canada justin
trudeau n'a aucune envie d'en débattre
on est dans tellement un moment complexe
et compliqué que de faire un changement
aussi profonde dans un système qui est
parmi les meilleurs systèmes les plus
stables dans le monde maintenant pour
moi c'est pas une bonne idée aux yeux de
justin trudeau c'est d'abord et avant
tout la stabilité et la continuité qui
importe au delà du niveau de popularité
du roi n'empêche la pression est
sûrement forte sur les épaules de
charles iii après tant d'hommages rendus
à sa mère des quatre coins de la planète
et si madeleine blé morin radio-canada
londres